on the 26th of April the 22 firm's
infinity saga of Marvel will come to an
end
until then the advance sale of Avengers
and game will break the records the
excitement until then is immense
however many fans also wonder at the
same time what will happen to the Marvel
Universe afterwards especially after the
purchase of 20 Century Fox by Disney the
specific question arises what will
happen to the x-men film series many
fans will be disappointed as Marvel
President Kevin Feige announced in an
interview with io9 that the next five
years of the MCU are already fixed and
that the x-men won't have a place in it
according to their own statement the
five-year plan for the time after
avengers end game was set long before
the Fox deal and will not include the
x-men
he promises however that the x-men will
definitely be taken care of but only in
a long time the upcoming two movies
x-men Dark Phoenix and new mutants will
be the last two x-men movies for a while
at the top of the agenda are the new
black widow movie guardians of the
galaxy 3 as well as Deadpool 3 the
superhero movies Shazam was just
released in the cinemas nonetheless a
second part has already been confirmed
if you take a look at the worldwide box
of his takings that's quite
understandable as the movie earned 170
million u.s. dollars worldwide which is
already a financial success due to the
low budget of 80 million u.s. dollars
there is much information about the
personal details yet except that the
scriptwriter and regain has been
contracted anyone who has not seen the
first part could easily be spoiled in
the following the plot has of course not
been officially announced but it's very
likely that Billy Batson and his
super-powered faster siblings will meet
the villains mr. mind that dr. sivana
this would make the second part
consistent with the comics which
includes several confrontations between
Billy and the monster Society of evil
the sequel probably won't be taking too
long either to be realized we'll
probably find out more about that in a
few month
the upcoming streaming service Disney
Plus has announced its plan for the
monster Inc spin-off monsters at work
this will be the first time in seven
years that Sally and Mike return to the
screen the plot of monsters at work will
take place six months after
first film the power plant discovered in
the first film is supposed to use the
laughter of children to draft the city
of Monstropolis the focus will be on the
young mechanic toilet task man whose
greatest dream is to work together with
his idols Mike and Saudi in the laughter
department of monster Inc the original
dubbing actress of Mike and Saudi Billy
Crystal and John Goodman are back again
John Ratzenberger sche and Jennifer
Tilly as Celia and Bob Peterson as Rose
will also be part of the game again the
producer of monsters at work is Disney
television animation and the release
date is set for 2020 the expansion of
Apple's upcoming streaming service Apple
TV plus continues after Hollywood stars
such as Steven Spielberg Reese
Witherspoon and talk-show legend Oprah
Winfrey have already announced their
collaboration the legendary Stephen King
will now also join Apple TV plus and
this with an eight-part horror series
called Lizzy's story featuring Julianne
Moore
based on the novel under the same name
by Stephen King a special surprise is
that even Stephen King himself will
write the script
in short the series is about a woman who
has to struggle two years after the
death of her husband so you can be very
curious what Apple will continue to
announce until the release of the
streaming service because the content
looks pretty competitive so far many
American musicians already denied Trump
the use of their music at Republican
events including Rihanna Pharrell
Williams and Axl Rose
now another small scandal has arising as
Warner Brothers is now about to take
legal action against Trump for
unauthorized use of Batman film music to
be specific Trump has broadcast the
video for the upcoming 2020 election
campaign on Twitter in which he used
music from The Dark Knight Rises namely
handsome errs why do we fall without
authorization he also had posted his
slogan make America great again over it
a studio speaker commented the use of
one a brother score from The Dark Knight
Rises in the campaign video was
unauthorized we use the appropriate
legal methods to have it removed by the
way the video is now blocked on Twitter
and we will see how the small legal
dispute between the US president and one
of the largest film studios in the world
and the upcoming Netflix series The
Witcher which is based on the books of
the Polish Auto Andre Sapolsky is now
being filmed in Poland to the joy of
many fans even though The Witcher video
game series is set in a fictitious area
the scenery is very much based on the
Eastern European middle age and the
Twitter channel Netflix which sure shows
us just how atmospheric the whole thing
can look with impressive shots of
landscapes and castle ruins that could
also come directly from the game so the
studio took the right step and many fans
will be grateful for the high
recognition value whether the new series
will be the sequel to The Game of
Thrones saga that is about to end as
many fans of both series speculate you
can see for yourself on Netflix at the
end of this or the beginning of the next
year
[Music]